this is the biomega OCO the OCO is the  perfect bike for city commuting for  people who want to get more than zero  exercise on the way to work a less than  a workout the engine of the bike is  incorporated into the frame so if you're  looking at it you might not even know  it's an electric bike  it looks little Space Age and that's  because one of the designers behind it  is the avant-garde architect yard angles  designers and people who think about  cities want people to be using public  transportation and they love people to  be using green transportation the  estimated range is 25 miles to 40 miles  I did commute to and from work with this  bike and it was a lot better than I  imagined  I wasn't super sweaty it's just a nice  solution because you want to be outside  and you want to feel like you're getting  a little bit of exercise